[Musique]
ah bonjour réponse tu croyais vraiment
que j'étais parti pour toujours
et que se passe-t-il ma chérie tu n'es
pas heureuse de revoir ta maman
regarde tes cheveux sont revenus aussi
long qu'avant n'est ce pas merveilleux
ap ap ap approche mon enfant il est
temps de retourner dans ta tour où tu
seras à l'abri
sécurité
[Musique]
cherry oui tu n'as pas toucher à ton
assiette en eau si si je t'assure que
j'ai touché j'ai déplacé mais eux du sis
à l'as tu vois ça fait pratiquement une
semaine il faut que tu parle avec elle
tu sais que ma dernière conversation
avec réponse ne s'est pas déroulée aussi
bien que je l'espérais
frédéric je te rappelle que tu l'a
empêché d'aller au delà des remparts
alors si c'était ça t'a conversation
père fille
moi aussi j'aurais détesté l'entendre ce
n'est pas parce que c'était un choix
difficile à faire que ce n'était pas le
bon mais voyons cassandra je sais bien
que ces rêves essayé de me dire quelque
chose en particulier ceux ci sefyu du
toit réponse tu ne dois dire à personne
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit là je
crois que le secret est plus ou moins
dévoilés tout le monde s'est tu as
trouvé ta chevelure de rêve mais si
quelqu'un apprend que c'est moi qui t'ai
idée a filé en douce quand ça s'est
produit
on enverra dans un couvent non mais est
ce que tu me vois dans un couvent bon
dans ce cas il faut que j'en parle à
eugène et non non non non non non non
tout ce qu'on va dire pour l'instant
c'est que tu t'es réveillé ce matin là
avec des cheveux longs mais eugène et
mon amoureux on n'a aucun secret l'un
pour l'autre
je sais que c'est beaucoup demander mais
je ne peux pas prendre le risque je te
prie ne dit rien aux jeunes me dire quoi
bon aller les filles pas de secret entre
nous ce n'est pas vraiment un secret
eugène je dirais plutôt que c'est un
sujet sensible
tu as dit sensible ah ben si bhl et tu
crois que cassandra est sensible ma
jolie j'ai rencontré des glaciers qui
dégageait plus de chaleur et de
compassion et qui bougeait plus vite
elle est trop lente réponse ces moyennes
très bien que tu peux te dire oui bien
sûr je ne la fais pas confiance je
trouve que tu parles trop un
pas du tout quand est-ce que je
travaillais à secrets de moi un exemple
merci d'un foulard en soie merci on
s'est bien amusés dire que vous devez
cette rencontre
[Musique]